skipping leg day is a lot like attention
it's a lot like attending a liberal arts
college and staying committed to your
cheating girlfriend in both cases you
are throwing your life away while also
acting like a butter soft simp who just
hopes things will work themselves out
[Music]
[Music]
like the former president I have a major
announcement
if you go right now to dailywire.com
shop
you can get your very own copy of the
yes or no game look at this we've got
game pieces in here we got a scorecard
we got cards this is the real deal we
had an initial run of these I think we
had about a thousand boxes of this game
they sold out instantly and so
unfortunately I I think we would have
sold 10 000 of these things had we had
them in time for Christmas you can't get
it as a stocking stuffer but you can
pre-order your copy right now and you
should pre-order because I think these
are going to sell out too the
aliwire.com shop you can play with up to
nine people test how well you know your
friends and family and loved ones
discuss all the most important issues of
the day debate do aliens exist what are
the merits of vegan suffrage what do you
know about God life the whole universe
head on over to dailywire.com
shop get your copy of the yes or no game
in the flesh
in the Box I don't know in the cardboard
we have in the flesh here
my very good friend of many many years
indeed Spencer Cleveland hey good to see
you I'm glad you're finally on the show
does the when you buy the games that
come with the day drinking it does it
doesn't you can it's not required that
you have a couple of coca-colas when you
play the game but you can and I for one
encourage you it enhances the experience
it does enhance the experience we have
our drinks I have a bit of a a girly
drink you know I actually think the
martini it's a manly drink it's the it's
the uh James Bond drink it's the James
Bond drink it gets a bad rap because
people put berries and things that okay
this is very important maybe this is
like you know a side piece but that that
is not a martini if you like sugar if
you've got like sugar around the rim
you're serving something else that's not
it's like a sexual beach now you have a
delicious glass of scotch I do I saw
this troll on Twitter who said it was
like you know all these conservatives
they they grow these beards to try to
look manly because it's a fake
masculinity and so I thought I not only
have a beard I have whiskey neat at 2 30
in the afternoon I
one of those manly conservatives you
heard about that's right yeah you know 2
30 is usually when I go to the dentist
okay Shall We Begin I'm ready Bring It
On
like porn violent or graphic video games
are bad for society and should be banned
there's a lot
there's a lot there of portions of that
question
violent or graphic video games
so I have to say whether you yes think
that's true or not I'm gonna put you on
the yes
I'm not sure this is like a how based as
Knowles
I know
and you've got me don't know I've got
you a no okay
conditionally yes you're right okay and
my answer conditionally yeah all right I
want to hear about the conditions But
first you have to drink I or no well did
I get you wrong oh it's your answer no
no you got me right so I guess you I did
okay okay very well so I say conditional
it's a real Margin Call only because I
do think that some video games can warp
your mind like when I was playing Donkey
Kong Country as a kid man that stuff had
me messed up okay I had misapprehensions
about monkeys yeah I was walking around
throwing barrels at people everywhere I
went and nobody yeah I was there I never
played a lot of video games but I I did
get a kick out of Grand Theft Auto oh
sure as I was so outrageous shocking and
but when I was learning to drive because
I had played Grand Theft Auto a lot
where all I would ever do is I'd try to
hit the guys on the motorcycle and make
them fall off the motorcycle yeah when I
was learning to drive there was a
motorcycle coming down the road okay and
I it all turned out okay
I had the impulse right oh to fear in
and hit him head on oh interesting
because I played this video game so much
that and so I think
in extreme cases uh-huh
there should be some regulatory
authority to set standards for video
games right but broadly speaking
like I wouldn't ban Call of Duty or
something like that yeah what's what's
your take okay well somebody obviously
knows me because they're trying to
they're trying to mess with me with this
question I mean I am
kind of Fate not famously but known as
some like a kind of video game Optimist
I think they they contain some of the
great works of art of Our Generation I
think like as fine art has dithered into
abstraction and security you can
actually turn on like Final Fantasy and
see panoramas like you know unlike
anything else that's being banned so all
of that to say like I'm a total lib
about this
um and part of this I think is probably
because my taste in video games is like
Crash Bandicoot like fuzzy fuzzy
mcfuzzerson defeats the evil dragon
and so I'm like these are great like
they're so beautiful I'm having so much
fun because in Crash Bandicoot you don't
um carjack hookers I think you can get
an expansion pack
you can reskin it well no and then so
then it's and I do I mean I like like
God of War was one of my favorite and
Gears of War everything is of War but
the Gears of War Game and and those are
definitely I wouldn't give them to a
child you know like and I think like
there's a huge Dome main of Parental
supervision and engagement it's one of
those problems that goes like way deeper
than the the thing that is the tip of
the iceberg it's like well the breakdown
of society like you know the failure of
the modern American family like the
corrosion of our values all the like you
know you'd have to rectify all of that
before I would be like and you also
should ban yeah the video but I I mean
like like movies I definitely don't
think you know I think there should be
some restrictions in place to make sure
kids aren't playing like right right
that's Auto I don't know they do melt
your brain so since we both got it right
we just chose to drink anyway yeah
naturally okay I'm that's I I can't the
the glass is too appealing it's too
appealing and it's the other thing I've
I've really restricted my drinking on
this show in some recent episodes
because we shot the thing at like 10 in
the morning and even for me yeah all
right even I am not that much of a
degenerate right all right you're up oh
boy okay so I get to pick
uh
wow I did not know this okay uh Stephen
Crowder is right one of the most
overrated writers in history is
Shakespeare I did not know that Stephen
Crowder thinks this I yes I had never
said that we pay no attention to facts
on this show so that may or may not be
I'll take I'll take them just pick
somebody Jeremy boring thinks that uh
yeah right that Shakespeare is the most
overrated writer
in history yeah a big claim
one definitely yeah this is an easy one
for me it would be a no that's a big no
has he ever heard of Tony Morrison
I know Zora Neal Hurston like there's
just a huge like that chick that wrote
the uh the poem at the inauguration oh
my goodness I mean I saw I was in a
Bookshop the other day and I saw two
collections of her poetry what was her
name I can't remember Amanda Gorman
Amanda I'm shocked to myself where'd you
pull that no idea yeah the things that I
don't know because I know that is
probably too depressing to think about
like there's some line of poetry I've
forgotten but I know Amanda Gorman I I
remember a line of literary criticism
where the late great literary critic
Harold Bloom referred to slam poetry as
the death of art
what's what's with the hate for
Shakespeare why would anyone hate
Shakespeare so I'm gonna make the
strongest possible case for this I mean
because for one thing it's impossible to
be more highly rated than I mean you
know if you leave aside the woke crazies
who likes his dead white man whatever
you know he is his name is like
synonymous with literary Excellence yeah
and I at least think that there are some
other writers in the English Canon
Milton for instance even if just you're
just restricting yourself to like
English language but yeah right there's
definitely other contenders for the
throne of the great poet of of English
um and the other thing you could kind of
a juice as perhaps Crowder does who
knows is that you know Shakespeare's
reputation is is kind of invented in the
generations after his death by you know
Johnson and Boswell and this you know
those great who put him on the stage
with like escalus and he's our you know
he's the the English languages but I
don't know man you know for God's sake
let us sit upon the ground and tell sad
stories of the death of Kings how some
have been deposed some sleeping killed
some poisoned by their wives all
murdered for within the hollow crown
that rounds the Mortal temples of a king
keeps death his court and they're the
anti since allowing him a breath a
little space to monarchize be feared and
kill with looks
and humored thus
comes at the last
and with a little pin
bores through his castle wall and
farewell King
cover your heads and mock not flesh and
blood with solemn ceremony for you have
but mistook me all this while
I live with bread
like you
taste want feel grief need
friends
subjected thus
how can you say to me
I am a king
remember to do though Justice be thy
plea consider them over Politically
Incorrect okay you're getting us banned
even without the bad questions
reading Merchant of Venice ultimately
when you're faced with a genius of that
uh totality which really I mean the
language aside is the completeness of
his vision of human life the capacity of
I mean we've been talking a lot about
Dante lately and I think he's maybe the
person you could put next to Shakespeare
before that just like totalizing vision
of human life uh it's got to come from
from one mind and I have no I've seen no
evidence why it shouldn't have been
Shakespeare and if it was some guy named
Bob like what difference does it make
Bob shakes I love when they say
Shakespeare was actually it was actually
multiple people and I think yeah because
you know you know what produces really
great art committees committees are
known for their artistic vision and
skill right
all right next question yes I am more
inclined and to believe that the Earth
is flat
then that bodies were recovered from
Roswell okay after we answer this we
have to diagram
so basically I'm seeing many verbs and
I'd like a lot yeah sneaking okay so so
I am trying to decide whether you think
it's more likely that the Earth is flat
than that bodies were recovered from us
all this is actually really hard I
thought it was easy and then it turned
out to be
foreign
hey boy oh boy okay this is good this is
a good one once we rewrite I'll drink
two just in solitaire
okay
no I I am
much more inclined to believe in the
Flat Earth theory since the Earth
actually is flat for all intents and
purposes this is Jonathan's big thanks
this is Owen Barfield yes Point yes okay
so that was why I instantly went for you
know and then I thought actually he's
probably gonna say that's one bar field
yes go on I I also
like demons exist aliens don't exist but
demons exist right but they don't have
bodies the definition of an angel or a
demon is that they're pure Spirit right
right so they didn't whatever they found
at Roswell or whatever you know was
Soviets biplane even if they found a
demon they wouldn't be able to grab his
body he doesn't have a body right right
but what about what about counter
argument what about what Beatrice says
to Dante when he asks her whether the
Blessed Souls really are on Venus or
really are she says they showed
themselves to you here not because this
is their sphere they all live in the
emperion but as a sign for you since
this is suited to your senses and in
this way the Bible condescends right to
speak of God as having hands and feet
but something else yes all of this to
say right like couldn't it might be the
case that although Angels and Demons
don't have bodies they could appear to
have bodies at Roswell yes I suppose
that's true but I guess the way I
picture that because we entertain angels
unawares and I I I I I could give you
examples where I'm quite confident that
this actually happened please but I'll
tell you you yeah I didn't reach out and
grab I kind of wonder if if there really
were demons or something you know at
Roswell the moment that the cops went
out there to get him it'd be like a bee
Ghost movie where they go grab them and
they're just like you know they just
kind of fall right in yeah interesting
now so
was I I was correct on the Flat Earth
thing uh you were right you're more
inclined to believe in the flat well but
only
is that what you said that I mean right
but only in this oh and Barfield which
he probably defined since people are
going to be watching us which is to say
that
the notion that there is a scientific
theory of physical space that not simple
it doesn't simply correspond to our
perceptions but actually outlines the
Bedrock of reality is heretical and a
scientistic fallacy yes this is why
right this is this is the problem with
Galileo it's not that he thinks the
Earth revolves around the sun it's that
he thinks there is an answer to does
this Earth revolve around the Sun or
vice versa which reflects some absolute
fundamental truth which makes a
fundamental truth physical rather than
spiritual yes okay yes because that's
what they say yeah sometimes if people
ask the Galileo question they'll say is
does the Earth revolve around the Sun
and I'll say man is the center of the
universe yeah I'll say but but you know
does the Earth in the the the best way I
have of describing reality yeah is that
man is at the center of the universe
that's right and they will say no no
yeah I get it you're using some stupid
metaphor to it but like literally
objectively yeah yeah example literally
and you're telling me that the fundament
of reality is some stupid rock I mean
Brad's not true nobody really believes
that right right and I mean it is in
fact true so far as I understand that
you can describe the universe as you
know revolving around the earth I mean
it's just the equations are a lot more
complicated uh but the fact that they're
more complicated doesn't mean that they
don't actually describe you know they
don't predict the outcomes of our
observations right that that is all like
it is a kind of a fiction a pernicious
fiction that when we write math which
predicts physical outcomes we are
somehow getting something more real than
the experience the quote unquote
subjective which by which people usually
mean arbitrary right experience of the
world as it occurs to our senses right
this is like a real problem and so the
argument that the Earth is flat is not
that if you walked far enough you'd fall
off it but that
for your experience in your experience
of the world it is flat you don't have
to account for its curvature as you walk
you can see it's you know so yeah I
think that's true although that's not
what the conspiracy theory I guess the
conspiracy theory is also scientistic
and is also referring to a physical but
but yes if someone said Michael well the
question that keeps coming up what is a
woman right is what is a woman and the
unfortunately the conservative answer
keeps being two X chromosomes and a
uterus that's right adult human female
adult human even that's better than 2x
chroma yeah you know the real answer go
on sugar spice and everything nice
that's a much more accurate and
destructive answer it is yes uh yeah I
would say you know it's a um two-legged
rational animal you know the female
gender right and yeah and these uh there
is this problem and this happens a lot I
think I I it occurred to me just the
other day that there's a certain form of
biblical literalism which is also
scientistic because you start out with
the true statement that everything in
the Bible is true and then you defend
that statement by trying to claim that
every word of the Bible corresponds to a
physical event in space and time which
you know again if you chase this down
you get like in the Psalms you get the
Earth revolving around the there you get
the sun rather moving across the sky or
walking around the earth and so forth um
and this is a con that that the libs
pull the traditionalists into which is
they say like oh well you can't prove
you know show me on a map and then and
then our response is like yes I can show
you on a map it's the XX chromosomes
it's the whatever
um and of course the response should be
that's a completely childish and
untenable view of the world even
according to science right like even
once you get down to the quantum level
you realize that perception does have
this like fundamental role right right
describe a kiss exactly like you're oh
it's it's when it's when these lips
which are made up of these atoms kind of
do this like the kind of it's like this
thing and then like some maybe a little
like a tongue if you're French kind of
and then that's what a kiss is right of
course okay here we go okay
okay well this is gonna be easy there's
no possible way that a gym selfie could
be considered an appropriate thing for a
self-respecting man to post on Instagram
uh well you know my answer to this but
I'm not sure I know yours
this is we're gonna yeah
they made me take away my phone for this
uh
uh okay no possible way
you're correct ah boy okay I'm gonna
drink it yeah I choose to as well okay
and I must have gotten this from you so
I guess it's sort of cheating but when I
think of orete when I think of real
Excellence okay I think yes we can
demonstrate our intellectual Aus oh and
yes we can we can demonstrate some
virtues through acts of kindness and
charity but also we need to post
physique is what we need to do because
the physical Excellence matters too yes
this is
in the central one of the central
chapters of my book which I should
probably talk about because it's not
supposed to like publish I would plug
that you know I'll plug the book it's
called how to save the west and there's
a whole section on the body of the
relationship between body so and this is
it's true it's a tricky thing because I
I accept the premise of the question
which is if I were to rephrase it I
would say there's no possible way that
most gym selfies that get posted are
something that a self-respecting man
would post on on Instagram on the other
hand
we live in a culture where
in order to break down every standard of
objective Excellence uh we are
constantly assaulted with ugliness yes
that is one of the major kind of means
of our you know I wouldn't even call it
you know I mean leftist is almost too
small a term for it it's like this you
know my friend James Willis calls it the
bore great it's this totalizing
um out of control kind of sameness and
and uh you know in in C.S Lewis's screw
tape proposes and toast he has a
perversion of democracy which is kind of
uh reflected also in like the
tocqueville that the total equalizing
impulse that I'm as good as you
everything as good as everything else
um and you know why are we constantly
being shown images of obese women in
their underwear right like that didn't
used to be the case I used to I remember
because I was a kid and the Victoria's
Secret Billboards and the catalog it'd
have super hot chicks and now it doesn't
and the minute you say this people say
you hate fat people which is like maybe
no no I don't I don't know Michelle
Obama over here friends are fat yeah
but the point is not at all what is the
range of things it's okay for a person
to be yeah the point is what do we
aspire to what what are our images of of
excellence and to deny that there's such
a thing as physical Excellence is
corrosive and demeaning and belittling
to people and and just obviously not
true we all know that it's not I know I
say this as an international sex symbol
let's recognize physical Beauty and
Excellence where it is exactly okay uh
did I read that one or you uh that was
me so that was you okay I read this one
America will not correct course and will
cease to exist as we know it before 2050
2050 yeah
correct drink
come on you you think I'm a pessimist
about this
yes I think that I think America is
doomed yeah you're an editor at the
Claremont review goodness gracious well
I know that pessimism is like a favorite
the past time of uh of the conservative
movement and I'm only saying no because
of the absolutism of the prediction
which I reject out of hand I think
nothing is written in the stars until it
happens I also think you know things
could go terribly wrong you can always
see how things could go terribly wrong
but there's a ton of you know energy and
excitement also about recognizing the
problem more than I think has been true
in a long time
um so no I I'm not a determinist about
about anything I think determinism is
unmanly you know I was wrong because I
underestimated your optimism
you were right because you
overestimated my optimism my my feeling
is that America won't be so
fundamentally different in the future
from where we are now it'll just kind of
yeah we're already on like a kind of a
bad path but maybe we can change it I
agree determinism is for wimps yeah yeah
users right right but
there's a difference between a
conservative Optimist and a conservative
pessimist that's okay conservative
uh pessimists as things can't get any
worse and a conservative Optimist says
oh yes oh yes they can that's great yes
I remember that yeah I mean it's big
like you know late Western Roman Empire
hours like 2050 is small that's nothing
compared to the like [ __ ] you know we
get like a horse as a senator we could
do anything they have in the same at
least
okay okay good
um stoicism is compatible with
Christianity
foreign
[Music]
yeah okay
go on I mean if you got me right it's a
hard question it's another one of these
hard questions because
Paul reaches for the stoics almost more
than any other I mean that I don't have
like a a tally but I feel like he's more
into the stoics than any other Greek
philosopher and and John the Prelude to
John's gospel in the beginning was the
word is obviously in some deep
consonants with stoic metaphysics
um but stoicism full stop
is incompatible with Christianity right
it's a the cyclical notion of time this
whole thing that like the soul dissolves
into atoms like or whatever this soul is
made out of right
um that's incompatible but I think
stoicism is one of the most easily
baptizable and most frequently baptized
forms I noticed a lot of kind of tech
Bros and Silicon Valley types got really
into stoicism in the last 10 years or so
yeah and I I think that is not contrary
to what I see as a Christian Revival I
think it's sort of part of the Christian
Revival but yes ultimately the two are
not this is I just I just wrote this
whole we're coming out with this new
introduction to the gateway to the
stoics uh we're just reprinting some old
translations but I wrote it forward to
it so I did a lot of this like you know
I went on the Reddit
forum for stoicism which is huge I mean
like who doesn't yeah every night you
know right before bed I'm I know you
think you're joking because half a
million people around like these these
Reddit Bros be like you know scrolling
through Epictetus you know
uh and they talk about this stuff and I
did find a lot of this kind of it's it's
sort of like Christian atheism you know
it's like I like the thing that this
delivers but I don't want to like yeah
metaphysics of it
um and so I do find a lot of people
being like well you can't really talk
about Gods anymore but you know it's
like well look I mean the things that
appeal about stoicism are all things
that you know we come to us through
Christianity like all men are brothers
right it's like so who's their father
right all men are brothers who's the dad
right we all Brothers yeah yeah exactly
I mean we're not it's not literally true
so something must be spiritual about
that and it must be real yeah um and I
do think there's like a Temptation among
these people to be like oh I got
stoicism now I have a now we're good
yeah yeah it's like you think you think
Titus is epic you know just wait until
you discover John yeah let me tell you
about let me tell you somebody held
Jonah Patmos yeah a little something
something yeah exactly it's okay to be
white is a racist statement oh
this is too easy
no I'm joking I'm joking
all right you white supremacist it's not
it's not that's not racist we're gonna
get kicked off of YouTube we are after
this I know no I think I'm sitting
across with Kanye here he's such a white
supremacist you know you just called me
a Jew I
uh no I mean
not only is it okay to be white not a
racist statement
but calling it a racist statement is how
you end up with actual white supremacies
you know I'm I'm truly is
open-minded sort of I don't get angry
I'm like the only guy in the
conservative movement probably other
than you who doesn't get angry we were
just talking about this backstage yeah
yeah yeah and I and I I don't think
about race almost ever but I think you
know if you're if you just come up to me
and you say like it's not okay to be
white you know I think like well all
right nobody would have ever had to like
you know I would have never it would
have been completely ungentlemanly yeah
like 20 years ago for me or anybody to
be like go out there and pump my fist
and be like it's okay to be white right
like that would just seem uncouth you
know and so naturally I think you and I
both are fairly affable at fellows you
know we don't want to like go out here
carrying signs that say things like you
know men or men you know nobody wants to
be better things to do with my time and
more interesting things to say but like
but if you're gonna call it into
question then yeah yes I got to say it
right yeah okay we should drink today we
should amen yeah cheers
all right my turn right your turn okay
these are great Libertarians you guys
did a great job good job yeah well done
everybody
uh we need to talk about grammar but
we'll get to that later Liberty
Libertarians are basically Communists
who either shower or don't live off
their parents that's that's the whole
thing well uh fair enough oh boy yeah
are you gonna make me drink for that or
no we obviously agree oh man I feel like
I have to make you all just to be like
nice but yeah we're all friends we all
like some of my best friends are
Libertarians yeah and that's what I say
some of my best friends are fat some of
my best friends are fat Libertarians
uh all right yeah but that is correct I
mean
um the statement's correct because the
Libertarians and the Communists I think
ultimately share the same view of
anthropology and ultimately they believe
that men are fundamentally individuals
born primarily in in as much as we have
a political life with rights and
entitlements and the commies say we're
all individuals and then they Bunch us
all up together and they're sort of a
hideous Collective and the Libertarians
just don't get to that next stage but
both of them reject the reality of man
yes not nearly an individual but is a
social being as a political animal born
into a family in time and space into a
community into a nation with I think
primarily duties and obligations and
traditions and he has rights and things
too but that's not the primary fact of
his political nature this is a great
argument and it's making me understand I
think what my answer to this question is
um
sorry do I have Jordan Peterson on the
show yeah right exactly
uh Dostoyevsky
in the narrator in in Brothers karamazov
very early on says socialism is just the
Tower of Babel project yeah done for
real the effort to bring Heaven down to
earth
and I think this is an extremely apt
statement and you are basically saying
Libertarians and
uh Communists have the same fundamental
idea about human personhood which is
that we are interchangeable widgets and
even though Libertarians don't chase
this to its logical conclusion that is
the Tower of Babel project let us all
have one language one place one you know
like just the total uniformity
um follows on from the idea of the
individual as seemingly autonomous but
actually just kind of empty right just
just a you know consumer a consumer B
um and so my answer is actually I think
going to be the same as my answer about
stoicism which is to say stoicism alone
cannot save libertarianism alone is you
know as like a totalizing philosophy of
the world is basically the metaphysics
of Communism but I know a lot of people
who have libertarian like ideas and
leanings about how we should operate
within a constrained sphere uh who are
not really con you know who think that
libertarianism is like an operating
system that you can run within an
already existing computer called America
yes and the critique of libertarianism
is well that computer is like now
completely has gone viral yeah it's
totally fried in part because of like an
excess of Classical liberalism so uh
yeah but go yeah okay but I'll drink it
but right why not in fact uh
okay and uh by the way Spencer I just
I'm going to give you a little show
business right now they're telling me in
my ear that they split this question
into two cards I feel like I got the
backstage you got it so this is how it
really works around are there is the
alien are they giving you like
directives they are they always are
they're speaking when I have an earpiece
in and when I don't this is all those
those computer theorists are gonna on
Twitter
conspiracy realist yes
conspiracy Scholars shall we say
we are being conditioned so that before
the 2024 election there will be a
transgender version of George Floyd
along with the subsequent protests and
social unrest
[Music]
I got this is a fun game I like this I
love this game yeah people should buy
this game it's a great game to get at
home by the way I don't know how much it
costs or when you're going to get it but
it is going to sell out so you actually
should I did that I did that just
because you let me plug my book so thank
you thank you very much they're gonna
they're gonna call this they'll call it
grift but really it's just friendship
boy okay so
um there will be a transgender version
of George Floyd you've already put my
drink I say no oh my gosh
um I say used to say I don't know what I
say or you don't know what I don't know
what you say I don't think you know what
you say either for that half the time I
create your answer by moving your
Martini
um
[Music]
yeah no that's not gonna happen there's
like 12 of them and I know that they're
they're trying to groom the kids now so
it's like 20 plus of gen Z according to
that one random survey right right and
questioning and everything but but uh no
there's a lot of kids out there who
think they're transgender yeah it's a
very different thing yeah from like yeah
um also it's just race is the line in
America that actually has been an issue
from the earliest days of the country
right whereas this new gender fad is
simply that there were no transgender
plantations yes there was not like an
actual crime against humanity like
embedded into our history vis-a-vis
transgender yes
um
whereas you're right like the the whole
thing about race in America is that
they're actually grabbing on to
something truly will happen traumatic in
our past yeah
um and the other aspect of this is It's
too specific it's like you know it's
it's a little tip I had
um
but uh I certainly think if they could
they would I mean the the version of
this that's kind of that is real
is and this if we're gonna get banned
for like five different reasons off of
YouTube This is the end of this show I
hope that's okay that's fine I had a
good run yeah right exactly it sold some
sold some games
um no the the version of this that is
real is the like transgender people are
being murdered on mass in the streets
right they kind of have this line that
goes on and that is created to and also
if you don't pump your kid full of
hormones they'll commit suicide so yeah
you've you've killed your kid right they
totally hold you emotional hostage with
all of these things which are lies right
these are not true things
um but no I don't think they can
fabricate out of nothing I mean I don't
think they fabricated George Floyd out
of nothing you know like so no yeah okay
yeah
I'll drink anyway yeah why not let's be
honest
I like where I like to start I like
roses 95 of our political issues in
America would be solved if benching 225
pounds was a requirement to vote
hmm well
hmm
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know I remember
one time maybe it was Ann Coulter
said we need to repeal the 19th
Amendment and she's I'm sure she said it
more than one time sure but I was
talking to Elise about this and Elisa
this was early on in our sweet little
Elise and my dating life and she goes oh
my gosh that's that's crazy you know
what come on and I sort of thought I
said well
what's the point of voting
because what what you are being asked
right now you sweet little Elise would
you give up your vote to have a better
political outcome so I thought of it and
I said because women vote for Democrats
and Men vote for Republicans it's more
complicated than that but basically but
basically that's right right and
I thought well young people vote for
Democrats and older people vote for
Republicans so if you told me tomorrow
Michael the only people over 50 get to
vote right would I agree to that I
absolutely would agree to that I'd lose
my vote right right but I'd have a
better political outcome for my
community
now I'm not saying I can't bench 250
pounds no but right if it were a risk
that I couldn't I still hypothetics
where you're not putting up three plates
for rest yeah yeah like a big Beefcake
dude yeah right exactly um I would still
go for it because it would have a better
outcome for my political Community yeah
this body by lasagna um well okay so uh
um
I am in favor of voting I mean I am not
a like everybody everybody must vote you
know like uh lower the age to five yeah
exactly
um twice in fact if you know if if
possible
uh so so I think you know I've heard
good Arguments for like you should own
land to vote you know I I do think the
question was what are political outcomes
be improved yes and the answer to that
question is certainly yes totally
um the other question behind it is
should we therefore do it and I'm I'm
not I'm enough of a lib to say just
because you get better outcomes doesn't
mean well you won't get it there's no
there is no no we're not gonna then
politics to actually do it but yes would
if only gigachads voted yeah yeah would
we have better political outcomes yeah I
just think that's a statistical fact
even even lib Jim Bros are way more
reasonable than lib like couch potatoes
totally yeah totally okay easy okay
anyway I'm up
there is at least a 51 chance JFK was
not killed by the communist Lee Harvey
Oswald
51 51 chance he was not killed by Oswald
I think he was killed by hate
there is
exactly no no he was killed by Oswald I
think do do the people who like I know
there was just this release yeah that
where Tucker did a whole segment where
he essentially said that the CIA was
involved in the JFK killing but
and this there are all these files from
the CIA and their relationship with
Oswald that was sort of have not come to
pass but even still does anybody say
that Oswald didn't pull didn't pull the
trigger I am not up on this conspiracy
theory this is like I I'm kind of I like
that I'm into the moon ones I'm into it
yeah you know like uh I mess around with
some of those yeah yeah but like this is
one that kind of bores me because yeah I
sort of think he did pull the trigger I
like yeah so no I don't think anybody
thinks it was like Grover like right
right yeah I don't yeah it wasn't just
LBJ sitting on the Knoll yeah yeah much
as he might have celebrated it would
have been delighted right yeah right
okay all right that's good all right
it's the only conspiracy Yuri
aha this is a good one the respect for
Marriage Act is neither respectful nor
about marriage
[Music]
respect for Marriage Act is neither
respectful nor about marriage so we're
saying
saying yes it is not respectful or about
marriage that's right if you agree that
it is not about neither of those things
you should say yes
foreign
[Music]
I was gonna say no now that you've said
that I think maybe I do think yes uh
okay don't don't drink and we'll explain
okay the sides of this I think
um because
well I'm gonna drink anyway are you
right right first of all did I did I get
it right no I would say it isn't it is
not about
respect or marriage I don't think it's I
don't think so I also have to so you
have to drink yeah yeah
so because I I was thinking you would
say well it is about marriage it's about
destroying yeah yeah yeah no other but
the the people who pushed it the libs
who pushed it I don't think they give a
damn about marriage and I don't think
they want to respect people I think they
want to drive Jack Phillips and
masterpiece cake shop out of business
and they tried to do it through the
court and the court wouldn't let him do
it and so now and it's not and they take
the obergefell decision which redefines
marriage and they they go further than
that and they say no no business right
no wedding website maker no cake shop
owner whatever is allowed to
uh not participate in a gay marriage
totally oh I think this is
uh that interpretation of it's not about
marriages is definitely correct you know
I think it's about it's nominally
obviously about marriage
um but I agree that and I I've I've
gotten a little red build on this way I
the moment is when they rejected the Lee
Amendment which basically just said in
the in the like kind of gentlest
possible terms perhaps you you know you
might have been a constitutional yeah to
sue not even an organization but an
individual out of existence because they
express and so
yeah I mean I think I agree with you
about a burgerfel I mean we're on the
same page I think about that and and I
think that you know when the when the
bill first came up I thought well I
truly believe that when it comes to like
some sort of
place in society for Freedom loving gay
people yeah like we can work this out
you know what I mean like we'll call it
floof we'll call it whatever like
there's something there's some
arrangement that makes sense that
recognizes that a man and a woman
producing children is at the center of
our Civic life is is marriage but there
are these Arrangements that kind of
still have a place narcissist I think
there's like I really believe there's
room for for which is reasonable that is
the sort of Jonathan pajo he made this
point on another conversation we're
having where he said you know if you
look at Medieval manuscripts um there
are all these kind of odd and eccentric
things all around the corners of the
page the marginality the marginalia but
they're not at the they're not at the
center of the universe no you wouldn't
want the guy who's like farting a demon
out
I'm not making that up uh
uh no but I think this is this is right
and I think that you know mo anybody
sensible of any political persuasion and
so I thought well maybe there is some
oh burgerfeld is not that and that's why
I dispute it not because of its outcome
but because of its logic is not that
it's the logic of that we talked about
this before the total owl is the same
you define your you define reality a man
and a man in a relationship is the same
as a man and a woman in a relationship I
think you can believe a man and a man in
a relationship is okay you can believe
it's not okay but you can't believe it's
the same nobody seriously believes
nobody can believe it right because that
means that men and women are the same so
that's they're not the same right
um and so when they when they rejected
little little Mr Lee who is like maybe
you might like to not sue people out of
out of business then I was like okay so
you're just totalitarian yes and so yeah
my Basics yeah I know right I know I'll
tell you one other thing about that bill
and then I guess we have to do another
question but I guess I don't know
because you're too interesting
um the other thing about that bill that
suddenly occurred to me is that all of
these things where they were going to
codify yeah because we found out that
actually you can't just write things in
if you just write things into law via
the courts you can actually unwrite them
and this whole it was this absurd thing
that they did where it was like
precedent you can't overturn precedent
it's like where does what like where did
Jenna return president like Plessy
this is settled law like you know
um right you don't want to do that so so
they found this out and they were like
well what we really need there for is a
bill to codify it's like I have a news
for you about Congress like every two
years
we bought in New people that it's like
if they ever did overturn a burgerfel
which I think they should do and re you
know I think we should relitigate this
question um if they ever did that like
you just vote on another bill so it's
like you can do it you don't need the
permission of the Supreme Court right to
pass a bill right yeah everybody wants
on all these questions abortion on gay
marriage everybody wants some
cataclysmic victory that is gonna We're
not gonna have to think about it because
one side won yeah yeah that ain't
politics in America like we are having
this let us have the damn discussion
again that's right okay yeah very good
point and I'm glad we both drank on it
even though I don't really I can't
remember what we said okay I mean yeah
that's the point of the drinking
skipping leg day is a lot like attention
it's a lot like attending a liberal arts
college and staying committed to your
cheating girlfriend in both cases you
are throwing your life away while also
acting like a butter soft simp who just
hopes things will work themselves out
did they make these like more and more
extravagant I don't think it's merely my
perception no no it's not the yeah okay
there's so much in that question I'm not
even gonna try to parse it I'm just
gonna take the spirit of it
right
yeah
which is a I was gonna say this is like
pretty self-funded
I call it like I said I like to think
I'm quite unbiased okay even when my
personal interest or ego are challenged
but hypothetically in Minecraft
hypothetically calling balls and Strikes
that's what I do yeah you're big into
neutral I'm a big neutrality guy
Michael Knowles famous neutrality
enjoyer average neutrality enjoy oh boy
generally speaking if Protestants were
to accept a tenant of Catholicism either
the Immaculate Conception or Purgatory
it's more likely it would be purgatory
there are a lot of Protestants
there are a lot of problems difficulties
yes yes many shades yes some say thirty
thousand
some might say that's a strike against
the protestantism and the great
schismatic debates but that's a separate
question
um
yeah yes okay right yeah for sure yeah
it's very hard it's very hard for many
Catholics to accept the Marian dog to
even accept that Mary has a really
important place in the faith for me I
was an atheist for 10 years I came back
into the faith in many ways through
Protestants some of whom now are
Catholic actually interestingly or
reverted to Catholicism but even for me
even well into it the Marion
stuff was tough for me and now
I find it so
enriching and edifying and sanctifying
and
like really Central
yeah if not if not if not perfectly
Central like quite close to it that's
right my this Protestant
would accept would take Mary before
Purgatory although I'm open to both I'm
kind of like both of them you know
um
I I am your ever I'm an average Mary
enjoyer and I think like but but the
reason the correct answer to this is yes
is that people are ready they'd be out
there ready to restart the 30 Years War
over this question I mean if you talk to
people they will be like the Catholics
they are the idolaters because they have
another God and she's a woman and
whatever they worship man they worship
Mary right worship no you need I mean
there is
um C.S Lewis says that what is beyond
time and space is so male that in
relationship to it we are all female
this is true this is beautiful and it is
right and just that the representative
of humanity in man's relationship to God
should be a mother and a woman that's
that's that to me that's the beauty of
the doctrine I disagree about the
Perpetual virginity there's also but yes
that I would I would go with that first
but I think most people would take that
right but on the next game we'll we'll
talk about marriage opportunity but it
is I I do remember I remember when you
got Mary pilled and yeah and or as you
became increasingly married and it is it
is harder it's purgatory
some of my Protestants you know they
don't like it but they can kind of
see more see more of it but yeah we'll
have to do a whole yes or no game on on
Mary yeah I think that the doctrinal
questions uh you yeah
it's me okay
Sisyphus
is rolling a boulder toward the grand
Hilbert Hotel the hotel has an infinite
number of rooms but they are full so
they may not be able to accommodate him
or his Boulder if he chooses to divert
his Boulder it will instead destroy the
ship of Theseus but the ship has had all
of its constituent Parts replaced so it
may not actually be the same ship is
Sisyphus happy
I think I know did people send these
questions in or did the producers just
write them I think the producer is just
right wow I feel like I know exactly who
asked this question but I can't it must
be wrong uh
it's too late in the game to answer this
question in a serious way uh also no
he's pushing a boulder you know that's
not you can't be this is not happy right
it's not always this is not happening
there will be no existentialism sympathy
on this your podcast we will not accept
even though no stoicism libertarianism
yeah fat people we can entertain all of
these possibilities but existentialism
is a bridge too far you get your dirty
Camus
uh if I had to pick between pre-mid and
post-tribulation oh I I hate myself this
is bad I'm like the least Protestant
process pre-mid and post-tribute I don't
know exactly uh I tend to side with the
Left Behind movie take and think Rapture
would be pre-tribulation
that sounds to me much more complicated
than the Sisyphus question it's vastly
more complicated and
this is a series of whatever but do your
answer and then I will show them well I
gotta move yours the wrong one so uh
uh I'm gonna say no because no yeah yeah
whatever I mean sure why not whatever
um
okay I'm I'm being the worst Protestant
here because this is like especially for
Evangelical Protestants this is a matter
of utmost concern I've had so many
people ask me about this this is about
the end times about the end times it's
about whether the Thousand-Year Reign is
gonna be I'm gonna get this so so bungle
but it's about whether like the Lake of
Fire and the Thousand Year Reign like
when is Christ coming in between like
when does Christ actually come back yeah
yeah and then what happens after that
what happens before it
to me
this is a question on which we are
expressly told we have no idea and no
one knows the day or the hour no one not
even the son but only the Father in
heaven and so I find all of this to be
vastly above my pay grade I think the
Book of Revelation is a profound Mystic
Vision which if read carefully it's like
people always say is is the Tribulation
is the Revelation whatever is it about
the sacking of the temple in you know by
the Romans after Christ's death or is it
about some Cosmic thing and it's like
yes yeah the answer is yes like you know
there are real historical events this
refers to and those historical events
because the Book of Revelation a
mystical uh description of the Holy Mass
yes yes yes it is right
um and so all of this simply to say
like stop worrying about it yes yeah I
agree yeah let's drink it let's drink to
that yeah yeah
uh you read the tribulation yeah yeah
science is fake and gay
obviously I mean right
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I've recently
been a little bit like
lived on this and that what I really
think is fake and gay is
scientism and I think that natural
philosophy is a venerable thing to do
and I think that people but I didn't say
or well I didn't say any of these but I
think I never I would never say natural
philosophies
I think most of the time
what people mean when they say science
is a thing that is fake and gay yes and
that is science yeah
yeah the uh referent of the word science
the understood record
oof it is okay to wear sweatpants in
public
hmm
it's very hard when one does not go to
the gym to understand the thinking of
one who does go to this what do you say
are you saying you don't no no no no no
yeah yes
I'm sitting here in my t-shirt with a
man in a suit no I think um
but you're not wearing sweatpants
that's right
I'm not wearing sweatpants the question
hinges on the meaning of the word in
public so I think I'm going to make you
drink because I I will swear I wish
about Pennsylvania you were correct on
mine yeah yeah yeah
um would you wear if hypothetically you
were to go to the gym would you wear
sweatpants too I would not wear
sweatpants in Prime no you would wear a
a bow tie to the gym I would yes I I
can't I I did no I wouldn't count the
gym as in public I mean I'm saying you
know right that's one walking down the
street I would not but there was a
period where the daily wire was going to
make a movie and I I was told to beef up
for this style I remember when I said
Body by lasagna I wasn't good
shoveling yeah yeah pasta pizza meat all
this stuff and I really did gain again
20 pounds and I cut my body fat in half
so it was actually muscle I never cut I
never actually cut yeah but I I no you
did it bro I totally I remember first
time in my life only time in my life and
I I did purchase a pair of sweatpants
for the occasion and a pair of sneakers
also yeah yeah and uh they have not had
much use since then did you when you put
them on did you scream Adrian
I tried to break my nose a few times so
that it would look convincing okay
most likely the Elites at the top such
as Bill Gates George Soros and Klaus
Schwab are all just possessed by demons
and or directly worship the devil in an
attempt to transcend the human race and
merge with their existence in a higher
plane
due to YouTube rules make your guess but
do not verbally confirm if the other
person guessed correctly give only an
ambiguous non-verbal
confirmation
Gates Soros and Schwab all worship
demons or are possessed by demons I feel
afraid to speak I think I've just signed
some sort of don't speak terms of
service
can we talk about it do we just talk
about
the things in the abstract in Minecraft
um
let me tell a little story when
Dobbs
came down as an actual decision when Roe
v Wade was overturned
I saw on Reddit in an in a Satanist
forum
somebody struggling with whether or not
to convert to satanism
and one poster said
satanism
isn't really about worshiping Satan
it's just about
bodily autonomy
and privacy it's really Enlightenment
virtues
and I thought boy do I have news for you
[Applause]
and that's my only answer to that
question
it's my very good answer all right very
good answer
the war in Ukraine is roughly five
percent crazy Russians and 95 money
laundering for the New World Order
you say
you are right yeah you have to drink oh
good okay all right I'm the yeah I don't
think it's money laundering for the New
World Order I think it's an imperial war
between the Western Empire and the
Eastern Empire of Russia and I think
that but any the the West is dishonest
when they say it's about National
Independence for Ukraine that's
obviously absurd it's about getting
Ukraine to join NATO and the the broader
Western Alliance and that's why when
there was a pro-russian leader of
Ukraine before 2014
we wielded our political power as great
powers do to influence the politics in
that country and
oust the pro-russian guy and put in a
more favorable pro-western guy and then
Russia responded to that by uh
increasing its influence operations
including military operations in Ukraine
and then Obama because he's weak wasn't
able to stop that and Trump was able to
stop these things he was able to at
least put a pause on them and then Biden
essentially invited Russia I mean it
actually invited Russia to invade when
he said if it's only a minor incursion
in the east then we won't really do
anything about it and so Russia did that
and Russia said it's unacceptable for
for Ukraine to join NATO and Ukraine is
a buffer State and buffer states often
do better when they play great Powers
off of one another than when they
declare allegiance to one or the other
that's often the proximate cause of war
and I think that's what happened in
Ukraine
all those beautiful Towers
uh yeah
um no that's very that's very eloquently
said
um I think people misunderstand this the
transgender question is is like this too
I think people misunderstand how the New
World Order works and I think you see
this with covid as well yeah that oh
it's the pandemic or they engineered
this in a lab to no no they don't have
they're nowhere near competent enough to
orchestrate these massive Global events
what's true is that they have a
totalizing philosophy about how the
world Works which is anti-human
which is
you know post-human in some ways which
is evil and wrong
and
which resp inclines them to respond the
only thing restraining that philosophy
is circumstances the fact that we live
in a country which is still nominally a
constitutional republic to which
politicians must still pay some form of
lip service in order to succeed and so
forth
um that held them back for however many
years from saying what they already
believed long ago about public health
it's not like
covid brought into being some new
attitude about public health right and
in fact it barely brought into being a
new virus exactly just a variation on an
old virus exactly and and so
similarly I don't think that any I don't
think that like money nobody
orchestrated the war in Ukraine to
launder money that right the war in
Ukraine happened for a number of reasons
among them those that you just laid out
um and it is the case that our
leadership class is feckless incompetent
and uh foundationally philosophically
wrong about metaphysics which makes you
evil being wrong about metaphysics makes
you evil even if you don't sit there
with your hand rubbing your hands
together right right good point uh am I
up or oh sorry it's you I'm uh it's you
okay
they are pervasive and key pillars of
some of the most influential and Wealthy
brands in America they strike at the
very heart of American civilization and
must be eradicated from society if the
West is to have a fighting chance of
survival but to mention them is to be
looked down upon with derision and
contempt
by they
and them
I mean
seed oils
wow I was a little nervous fellas yeah a
little nervous
dog come on at this point does this need
defending yeah at this point I believe
that one's view of seed oils is far more
indicative of one's entire political
Outlook and whether or not I agree with
a person then their view on
immigration or whatever right it is one
of the most defining political issues
even though it seems somewhat
uh out of left field yeah these are way
deeper signifiers then this is like a
generational thing that you have a hard
time explaining to older people because
it is it is a definitely more of a
millennial yeah yeah this is why you get
it's not because boomers are like stupid
or wrong yeah it's like you know they
say things like you don't believe in
like unfettered free markets like you
must be because like that was once that
was once seed oils like that was once
the like signifying exact issue
but the seed oil thing I'm total I'm
totally totally and I get more pushback
on this than anywhere but also more
engagement like people are you know how
crazy Elise has gotten with this sweet
little is it she she says to me she's
going down the rabbit hole no Plastics
in the house and well I mean there's
Plastics but not with our cooking that
we heat up and no seed oils it's all
butter or avocado or olive oil which I
think are much tastier anyway but then
she goes to me she says Mac
what you got to get rid of your right
Right Guard deodorant and because I have
I'm like an older I'm an old man so I
use the spray aerosol
that's pure poisoning like okay what do
I have to do she goes I got this
deodorant that you got to try it's made
of and I kid you not it's made of
grass-fed beef Tallow I was honestly I
was gonna say Yak butter and it wasn't
far you were not far away you were too
timid yeah yes right
do you know so I I said how much does
this cost I'm still on my first bottle
and probably my only bottle I said how
much did you pay for this is that what
this is is that I've been wondering
this beautiful musk this is an aromatic
sort of natural yeah right
how much did you pay for how much should
I pay for this and I want to tell you
how what was it was it because my Riker
is like three dollars I said it was it
like was it was it like five or six
dollars
no ten
no
22 and I think do I really want to live
that bad do I want to live 22 dollars
bad I don't know I shave a few years off
my life I save twenty two dollars yeah
yeah I think that's how much fine you
care about the ozone layer yeah if I'm
in a state of grace I'll get to go to
heaven eventually yeah it was a million
or two years in purgatory no I think
this is uh a million years in purgatory
you know it's like this or that
um no I
that is hilarious
and the question is not
are are our Foods killing us the
question as you say is how much are we
willing how much we're going to do about
it now I remember when this was a lib a
crunchy granola lib thing and now it's
like a total hard-wing white nationalist
like anti-backs used to be a crunchy
granola lip thing yes no it's a totally
worth it right it just depends on my
biggest conspiracy theory I'm gonna say
this the first time I'm saying this on
camera but I've said this to a lot of
daily wire guys we you and I will live
to see the day when nicotine is good for
you when the health industry your mouth
yeah amen amen
oh dang speaking of conspiracy this is
my this is my big conspiracy theory
uh I don't know how to pronounce I still
I actually I refuse to learn the fact
that you just said that I bet I could
tell you do you know what it's going to
be yes if it's your this is yours this
is my personal proprietary conspiracy
theory does it have to do with a certain
secretary it does transfer okay it
certainly does somebody knew
first of all I still don't know and I
refuse ever to learn how to pronounce
the name that begins this question
um
chasten Buddha catch is is most likely
aware Pete is a deeply closeted straight
CIA plant
I mean duh obviously how could they do
it without his this is actually your the
first and maybe only time I've heard
this is from you oh yeah nobody else
this is my eye totally I I'm actually
Buddha judge is not gay that's you I
will almost this is my theory I will
almost never claim ownership over if I
see an idea that I think maybe somebody
got this from my piece whatever this is
one that I will I will die on this hill
I invented this but I'm sure I'm right
that that man is not a homosexual yeah
yeah he's he's an opportunist yes and a
cynic he understood that the way the
wind was blowing you could never as a
kind of you know ivy league I don't
actually know a few times probably ivy
league Harvard I think it was a Harvard
yeah yeah so ivy league yeah you know uh
veteran
JFK mold lib yes once he realized that
that was passing away and you had to
take an identity box what's the identity
box you can check yeah easiest yes Mario
marry a man now do you have evidence for
your theory
other than his bat look taste the
evidence
is incapacity to match his ties with his
slacks like
that's good evidence yeah right I tell
you you know because some of the
audience might not know yeah that we're
college buddies that's right going back
to your freshman year myself yeah when
you said we've known each other we've
been friends for more years yes many
many years and but because we went to a
very liberal Elite School yes we know a
lot of these guys we do a lot of these
guys and there's a type and they're all
they all look like P they all look like
people they all kind of you know no it
just kind of sound like Pete and they're
all they're going to go get a job after
college because they're really
passionate about management totally
Consulting consultancy I just really
want to improve efficiency within
certain corporate uh structures
and then he he goes and he you know he
has he is a military veteran yes and he
the ivy league and he did the corporate
Consulting and he's just the perfect
political candidate except old Pete is a
pretty bland white guy and so you're
saying he had to have
something and I I don't understand why
it's more artificial than any other part
of his personality for him to pretend
you know what I mean like all these guys
are cooked up in a lab they yes you know
carefully curate as as we know from the
rubbing shoulders with them they
carefully curate every aspect of their
life including their disavow of the
curation right like including like oh I
just I'm so like you said I'm so
passionate about like you know
synergistic incentivization of uh of
flight spreadsheets birth control in in
Africa whatever like name it but then
they get into power and they right and
like that pipeline was so clear that he
wasn't a little little thing like being
a heterosexual stuff like yeah look look
for the right price yeah on whatever
sexuality yeah you know I mean it's like
it was better than like castrating
himself and being the first trans
lucky Pete in just five years just in
time because let me tell you that gate
is closing on white gay men
yeah right the established power class
exactly so do we know who won I think we
both won Spencer I I feel that I won and
I think
probably did
no I mean by just by being here yeah
yeah yeah we but you're right
I'm a little ashamed of us because we've
gone out many times and many many cigars
many many we only had you had your full
drink I I'm a little child here I only
had half of my well we were so engaged
in you're right the profundities you're
right that's true Spencer you've already
finished yoursen see your health yes we
will see you next time on the yes or no
game
[Music]